thank you I'm really excited to get to
host this panel with two greats
going to start with Jessie J I just said
I was saying you're right a moment ago
cesky and kc king Jessie's gonna start
off talking about outer space and I
guess how we find planets from data and
then KC's gonna talk to us a bit about
big data and human trafficking here on
earth so I'll just turn it over to Jesse
and we're gonna have two 20 minute talks
and then they're gonna come up here and
we'll ask them questions jointly hello
thank you all for for being here in
Keighley for your great work and
organizing I was really excited to be to
be asked to speak so the theme is data
on earth but we could think of it also
as data on earth's right so we're gonna
be looking for for other planets so
that's what I will be discussing this
work is in collaboration that has grown
over the past few years between Yale's
Department of astronomy in particular
led by Professor Deborah Fisher in
several PhD students and postdocs in
that department and then in my
department we have a couple PhD students
and a postdoc and then also several
external collaborators all of whom are
astronomers so what is the problem here
well ultimately what we're trying to do
is find exoplanets and in particular we
want to find low-mass exoplanets so
earth analogs we can even think of and
the problem is that when we're looking
for low-mass exoplanets rather than
jupiter-like exoplanet things like
stellar activity such as this large spot
maybe it's this large spot that we see
here this is a sunspot right so this is
an image of our Sun and there is some
activity that goes on on the surface of
stars like our Sun and this spot here it
turns out can cause problems and the
problem is that this can
like a planet when we're observing it
from very far away so what I'm going to
focus on with this presentation is
something quite simple and what I'm
going to try to demonstrate is that
embedded in the data that we gather is a
way to distinguish the signal from
stellar activity like these spots here
from the signal the signal of a planet
so just to begin so what is it an
exoplanet it's a planet orbiting a star
that's outside our solar system
okay so orbiting a star that's not our
Sun and the search for exoplanets has
become quite successful recently so what
we have here on the figure on the left
is discover a year of a exoplanet and
then on the vertical axis we have the
cumulative number of detections and then
the colors are indicating the way or the
manner in which the exoplanet was
detected at least first detected and in
red we have what's called the radial
velocity method and that's what I'm
going to be focusing on today is using
the radial velocity method to detect
exoplanets in green we see that more
recently it's been very successful
that's due to NASA's Kepler mission
which uses what's called the transit
method for detecting exoplanets so just
monitoring the total light output from a
star and looking for a little dips
periodic dip suggesting that a planet is
transiting so that's another great way
of detecting exoplanets but like I said
we'll be focusing on the radial velocity
method and I'll explain what that is the
figure on the right we have the first
publication date on the horizontal axis
and then on the vertical axis we have
the minimum mass of the exoplanet that
was detected and we see that as the
publication date increases that we're
finding more and more low mass
exoplanets but then there seems to be
more recently this bottoming out this
we're kind of hitting a wall around 1.5
Earth masses that's the M
sub-e so um one earth mass is the mass
of the earth of course and and there are
some issues with getting below this this
kind of threshold we have here and in
order to find earth analogs so these low
mass or low mass exoplanets that that
we're seeking okay so what is the radial
velocity method at its core what we're
looking for is a wobble in a star so how
do you detect a wobble in a star well we
have this very simple planetary system
the red ball is a star the blue ball is
a planet that's orbiting the star and
the X is the center of mass of the
system due to the planet orbiting the
star the red ball is going to have some
motion due to the gravitational pull
from between the two objects and if we
are over here on the Left see if we can
over here on the left and watching this
star from so from Earth or just outside
were looking at the star the star is
gonna have some forward and backward
motion since this star so really any any
object that's emitting light and is
moving towards or away from us if
something happens to the light output
from that object and in particular if an
object is moving towards us and emitting
light the light waves get kind of
crunched together or or blue shifted is
what we'd call it and if when the
objects moving away the light gets
stretched or red shifted and we actually
noticed this with sound waves - like if
you have an ambulance coming up behind
you it's very high-pitched high
frequency shorter sound waves and then
once the ambulance passes it kind of
drones off and it's kind of more low
frequency so sound waves and light
weights have this similar property and
so what we are looking for then is a
blue shifting and red shifting of the
light from the star and if we can detect
this in some periodic pattern
that suggests that a planet is present
or at least some object orbiting the
star is present so what type of data
would we gather for the radio velocity
method we gather the stellar spectra on
the horizontal axis we have wavelength
and the vertical axis is you can think
of it as a distribution of light coming
from the star at these different
wavelengths or the intensity of light or
the number of photons hitting the the
CCD and so if an object is orbiting the
star that we're observing if the object
if the star is moving away this entire
spectrum is gonna move a little bit to
the higher wavelengths right it's going
to shift a little bit to the right and
then when it's moving towards us it'll
shift towards the bluer wavelengths so a
little bit to the left eye that sounds
like it should be easy to find but these
these shifts are would basically be
undetectable if I were to show you the
shifted curve unless it was a very
massive exoplanet so what is typically
done then is that spectrum is turned
into a single number and that number is
the estimated radial velocity of the
star at the particular time that the
spectrum was gathered that the data were
collected and so if you do that across
time so you get a time series of the
stellar spectra and you turn each into
one number you can plot what's called
the RV curve the radial velocity curve
for the star and so here I'm showing one
from 1995 it's 51 pegasi and at with
this these data they discovered a an
exoplanet and that exoplanet is about
150 Earth masses and this this negative
to positive to negative pattern that we
see here so think of phase for now just
as times across time the star is moving
towards and away and towards us the semi
amplitude here is about 50 meters per
second okay so it's from detecting
this shape in the radial velocity curve
that suggested that an object is
orbiting and due to various theorems and
laws and things we can actually estimate
the the mass of the planet from this
okay so this was from 1995 and then if
we look at a more recent dataset this is
from 2011 where they also detected an
exoplanet that is a minimum mass of 3.6
earth masses and suddenly the the
patterns not so clear right so if it
turns out that the semi amplitude is
about point eight meters per second we
see that there's a lot of scatter
there's there's uncertainty in the
measurements but ultimately they were
able to discern this curve that
suggested an exoplanet is present okay
so between 1995 and 2011 the instrument
that was used to gather these data
dramatically improved which was why we
there's even any hope at detecting an
exoplanet of this mass okay so again
about one meter per second is the semi
amplitude so with that in mind what we
want to find our earth analogs and so
looking for an earthlike exoplanet
orbiting a sun-like star we have to be
able to detect a semi amplitude of nine
centimeters per second okay so that's so
good this is about one meter and what
we're looking for is a signal that's
about nine centimeters per second so the
instruments that are being built the
spectrographs have been improving and at
the end I'm gonna mention one of the the
newest spectrographs that was developed
by an astronomer here that gives us some
hope that we might actually be able in
terms of the instrument be able to get
to this level of precision in order to
detect earth analogs but it turns out
that that's not the entire problem so
the instrument is is one part of it
making sure that we have the resolution
needed in order to detect such a tiny
shift but but then it turns out once we
get down to that level of precision in
the data there's something else that
comes up and I already mentioned this
near the beginning but the problem is
with stellar activity so stars are not
solids they're actually a plasma lots of
things are going on magnetic activity a
lot of motion and so they're all these
different effects happening on the star
can cause distortions and the data which
isn't necessarily a problem until those
distortions end up looking periodic and
when they start looking periodic in a
particular way that's when they start to
look like exoplanets and so it turns out
that if there is a spot present on a
star that spot it can move it can shrink
it can grow it's not going to live
forever it might have a lifespan of days
two weeks but but it will rotate with
the star and and due to certain other
properties in particular the fact that
when a star is rotating half the light
from the star is coming towards us the
other half is going away so half of it
gets blue shifted the other half red
shifted if you start considering spots
like these dark regions here and that
spot is rotating from a blue shifted
region to a red shift of region in the
data that starts to look like a Doppler
shift okay so we need to be able to
discriminate the effect of stellar
activity from the effect of a real
Doppler shift in order to detect
exoplanets successfully the risk is if
we don't do that we will come up with
false detection and then the field can
lose credibility people stop trusting
when a real detection happens and so
forth so we don't want to have false
detections that's that's not good so the
question then is can we disentangle
stellar activity and Doppler shifts by
actually looking at the spectra right so
previously we would take the whole
spectrum turn it into one number and our
question is can we go back out
spectrum and get more information than
that one number summary and so what
we're gonna look at next is a time
series of simulated spectra where I'm
going to demonstrate that the effect due
to a single spot is can be discriminated
from the effect due to a single planet
it's a very simple idea but but we first
wanted to demonstrate that that
information content who is even in the
spectrum or in the spectra so what I'm
gonna use is our simulated spectra from
the spot oscillation and planet code and
this is an example of a simulated
spectrum it's actually using real
spectra from the Sun and then putting a
real spot spectrum into the data so so
what we're going to do then is add a
spot that that has a coverage area 0.1%
a spa with a coverage area of 1% and
then 5% so these are increasing sizes of
spots and we're gonna so that's going to
contain that's going to be three
separate data sets and then we're going
to consider three data sets with a
planet one has a one meter per second
planet a ten meter per second planet and
a 50 meter per second planet so that
this is increasing the strength of the
signal coming from a planet and so each
of these six data sets have a time
series of twenty five spectra and we're
gonna look at at what happens to the
spectra with these these different
effects applied to it alright so the
many of you I'm sure are familiar with
principal component analysis right most
introductory stat courses will cover
this but but not everyone has taken
stock or so I'm just gonna mention that
what we do just to investigate details
in the spectra is we take each spectrum
let's say there are a hundred thousand
measurements on one spectrum so instead
of thinking of it as a spectrum think of
it as a point in a 100,000 dimensional
space right really easy to imagine and
and
we're gonna look for the directions of
the most variability among those
wavelengths so here I just have a
three-dimensional projection so each
dimension is a different wavelength and
then each point is that representing
that part of the spectrum and so the
first principle component finds where
most of the variability is and it so
that's that that one area with the PC
one on it and then PC two finds the next
direction of variability orthogonal to
that first one and and defines that
direction and then it continues on in
that manner so the first principle
component captures the most variability
second principle component has the
second most variability and then so
forth so we're going to then take those
directions and color the spectrum
according you can think of it almost as
weights so the first principle component
is telling us how much of each
wavelength is contributing to that
direction and they can contribute in
sort of an opposite way positive or
negative or close to zero where it's not
really contributing much and so there's
it says faq' late there we're just going
to ignore the fact left for now and only
look at the spot in the planet so here
we have these three figures and they're
each cutting out a portion of the
spectrum and the redder regions are have
a positive weight and the negative sorry
the blue regions are negative weights
and if you compare the spot versus the
planet you'll see that the blue versus
the red is different between them the
the planet is actually doing just what
we'd expect we'd expect half the line to
look blue the other half to look red
that's what would happen if you just
imagine taking one of these one part of
the spectrum and shifting it the
variability is going to be opposite on
on each side but then with this spot
it's doing something different the very
the core of some of the lines let's see
well I'll just
so this seventeen point five the core of
the line is red and then when you get
towards the top of the line it turns
blue so it's doing something different
from what the
planets doing so that's a good sign
saying that somehow the information due
to the spot is behaving differently from
that of a planet and then what we
started to look at is okay well that the
simulated data is essentially perfect
data there was no noise added it was
high resolution so we had a lot of
information would if we start playing
with the level of noise and playing with
the resolution and then we wanted to
count how many principal components we
could count as we change the amount of
noise and and the resolution and so I
won't go in just due to time I'm not
going to go into many of the details
here but if you look at the left column
in the right column this is colored
according to how many principal
components were discernible from noise
and again we see that the planet versus
the spot looks different and in fact the
variability due to the spot is is
somehow distributing into the components
differently from the planet alright so
so that gave us hope that the patterns
look different and so that we can be
developing methods now to better
discriminate stellar activity from a
Doppler shifts and I had mentioned
you're the beginning that there's a new
spectrograph that has been developed I'm
Debra Fischer professor Debra Fischer is
in the white lab coat sitting down and
then some of us statisticians are just
in awe of this instrument that she built
with her team but but it's going to it's
already providing very clean high
resolution stable data and just to
illustrate this figure on the right on
the left is the 51 pegasi data set from
1995 that I showed earlier and you see
the scatter that's present there on the
right this is kind of the first check of
Express and already we can see that the
data this is with the noise to that it's
significantly better from what we've had
previously and so with
hope is with our on the statistical
methods for developing and and some
other aspects of projects are working on
that will be able to detect earth
analogs soon okay so with that I'll
conclude and just say that the rate of
velocity method has been quite
successful there are some problems due
to due to stellar activity there's a
bunch of us especially here at Yale
working on it and it's very exciting
lots of interesting statistical
challenges and and we're hopefully going
to have some really great data soon so
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]